on le savait chanteur et compositeur on
savait moins que depuis toujours il
peignait nino ferrer expose ses oeuvres
à la coupole la célèbre brasserie de
montparnasse
une trentaine de tableaux qui parle de
la vie des femmes et de l'uimm elle
marie claire gauthier yvon bodin ont
rencontré l'artiste à la coupole
je parle en mon salon et chez moi une
grande maison dans le quercy on vit
beaucoup dans la cuisine il y adeux
souvent de la musique
alors pendant que je suis en train de
peindre souvent j'entends quelque chose
de loin qui me firent l'oreille alors je
vais je vais demander ce que c'est mais
en général je fais pas de musique ou
alors du mozart
je
et
j'ai pas toute ma vie et je pense que
que tout l'artiste se dire une personne
qui a une nature des artistes
s'expriment
au moyen de différentes disciplines du
coup musiciens qui sont aux peintres
écrivains sculpteurs même temps moi
j'aime aussi à ranger les maisons
dessiner les jardins
on regarde ce que michel-ange a pu faire
puisque monnaie a pu faire bon c'est
tellement éblouissant que je me sens
vraiment d'une immunité totale
mais arrivé à mon âge se dire à 60 ans
maintenant cette humilité je ne
m'empêche pas d'estimer que j'ai le
droit le plus absolu de peindre si c'est
ma nature me pousse à cela et si on
répète que ferme de conclure de la joie